las vegas honoring the life and legacy
of senator harry reid senator reid
passed away tuesday and tonight numerous
resorts and hotel properties are
honoring him with messages up on their
big boards on their marquis the marquis
can be visible up and down the strip
as we await details of public services
to honor the late senator harry reid
friends and family are remembering
reed's 82 years of life and how he
affected and impacted them the i-team's
david charns talking with clark county
commissioner tick sagebloom about how
reed inspired him
well tick-sagger-bloom says he was more
of an admirer of senator reid both from
rural nevada towns both holding
important positions
if he called you know
you took the call clark county
commissioner tick sega bloom says that's
what you did when harry reid was on the
line he would always cop said this is
harry
you know randle off a few things and
then hang up the phone
sigerbloom says he was more of an
admirer than a friend they shared morals
in a political party it was reid who
pushed him to run as chair of the
democrats in the early 90s a ray
sagerbloom ended up winning last time i
talked to him he said whatever you do
don't
say something you don't believe in don't
let them push you into something just
stick to your guns and i think that's
really if you ask anybody about harry
reid that's who he was
it was segrebloom who pushed for the las
vegas airport to now bear that legacy
the name change financed all through
donations
it's really a teaching moment and
hopefully that that name
represents when people come here from
all around the world a lot of people
know the name now we'll recognize that
and then locally we'll appreciate it no
matter your political leaning
appreciating a politician who always
pushed for nevada having somebody who
could literally pick up the phone and
call anyone in the world and they would
answer the phone and respond and
especially the president made a world of
difference as far as
lake tahoe
pyramid lake
whatever all our issues here in las
vegas